new game i was gonna play
who's i gonna play this vanguard
vanguard live
yeah twitch partner who i still need to
follow
um newer player i think he said he's
only been playing for three months
i still i'm gonna show no mercy but i'll
try and be instructive
and we'll see how to perhaps punish the
the play of a very new player
seems like he understands basics
not playing a safari gamut that's uh
it's a good start
um i'll play a ponziani
i'll play a ponziani um
i think this opening is it's direct
and
it can it can lead to a nice position
like nice center
uh we'll see see what black does oh d5
is the best move
i think he he was watching earlier he
was watching earlier and probably heard
that
i said this um so d5
the idea is for black is if i take and
queen takes
the queen is very strong here because i
don't have knight c3
uh however i'm prepared for this there's
queen a4
yeah a delayed stream snipe
be careful what i say in the past
so now i assume my opponent should be
on their own um and the idea with queen
a4
is i'm painting the knight there's a lot
of pressure in the center
i had this position once in a tournament
game
against sam sevien he beat me in
he beat me in like 20 moves it was a
very short game
one of my quickest ever tournament
losses
so this is the first mistake bishop e6
normally like this would be a good
developing move control the center
develop your bishop but it didn't
acknowledge the fact that the queen was
pinning the knight
which left the pawn undefended um
so going back to this position it wasn't
wasn't so simple to actually defend the
pawn because bishop d6 allows this
so the best move is either f6 or queen
d6
which are not not the easiest moves to
find
so no mercy i want a pawn and now
attacking the knight twice knight is
still pinned
um so we trade
and kind of traded ponds
i actually have to think there's a
couple options here i could take and
like win the pawn uh more attractive is
probably either this
or this
i really like bishop e5
in general you shouldn't capture a
pinned piece if you can just
keep building up pressure
um i'm still keeping the option open of
taking on c6 and also
pawn is still hanging and there's a few
ways for black to go terribly wrong here
which i won't say because
opponent might be watching 97 97 is
probably one of the
the best moves
i was gonna i was gonna maybe mention
queen d5 runs into this
this with a triple fork almost a wooden
shield
but 97 reinforces knight i could still
take
twice or even three times
but i think i'll take the pawn first
because knight still pinned and attacked
three times
and yeah i'm up a pawn so one back the
pawn
now it's a question what uh what plaque
does
for your opinion does chess improve
concentration
um
maybe in some respect yeah
like it kind of does teach you how to
stay focused for
extended periods of time
[Music]
um
but in general i would say like sleep
exercise and diet and discipline are
more more helpful
for like good concentration and focus if
that makes sense
but chess is just an activity where you
have to you have to practice
concentration
so i guess in some respect it does
it does teach you how to uh
to maybe find your zone
queen d6 okay so defended like there
there were three attackers against the
knights
um now there's three defenders so if i
take i don't win anything
but the light's still pinned so don't
have to take it
d4 is nice because i'm getting ready to
develop another piece
oh yeah some debate of of how to
pronounce lee chess
so the li it stands for libre
it's not an acronym it's just
uh yeah libre meaning free
so it's not lie chess it's not lhs
it's not lie chess.com or leches.com
and org sometimes throws people off as
well
a lot of ways to mess up the name i
think
there is a youtube video like if you
google
let's see if i can find it how to
pronounce
yeah lee chess
lee chess lee
chess there we go okay hopefully people
are now
informed
so queenside casting that's a good move
because it broke the pin
gets a king slightly away from danger
i'm gonna play bishop f4
i could also so i could take and
simplify but
i enjoy adding more pressure i'm just
trying to create situations where
it's easier for black to blunder
so the bishop aligned with the queen i'm
threatening so many nasty things
threatening this or this or this all of
which would
discover the attack and then eventually
win the rook oh
counter attacks not sure why i chose to
go into this stuff
in the headlights uh it happens
thanks for the bits followers and thanks
for the game
yeah it was actually i think it was a
good kind of lesson
um it's not bad to go for the stafford
like objectively it's
it's close to winning for white um
just next time go for it and understand
the line a little bit deeper
you'll have better chances
so this is interesting because
um i could i could counter the queen
like counter attack the queen
i will pronounce oh lyches
lichus yeah
i'm gonna keep all the tension because
if i move the night anywhere i lose my
queen
and then we're probably just trading
so far i'm like i honestly thought my
point was going to be much worse
because they said that they've only been
playing for three months
okay now um
[Music]
yeah the i think this is actually the
first like really big blunder
um the question is so i want to go
for like which rook do i want to go for
or do i go for the knights
oh it's actually not so simple though
wait a minute
because my bishop's not defended anymore
i probably should have played queen f3
i also have this move
wait i can just okay i can take here
queen takes f4 and then queen takes
that's almost mating actually
queen takes e6 and then the rook has to
block and then i take on e7
takes and then every every move comes
with check
i just have to be careful in the end if
i take here there's queen c1 so i
probably just castle
and it's okay
so i'm attacking the queen
though it looks like three three of my
minor pieces are hanging
but okay this is hanging this is hanging
so basically everything is hanging
it's 2 12 am for me this is probably my
last game
maybe oh stockfist just joined
what's up sokkas joining late it's been
a long stream
been a fun stream though
had a nice variety between this bullet
tournament
discovering this new crazy opening
man i also have to post i'm trying to
keep up the
the flow with youtube
i'm gonna have to edit upload
tag make a thumbnail because i don't
have
anything in the queue
this looks fun the boat has gambit but
not necessary
let's take the knights
and then i'll take with the bishop
yeah so this is the position i was
referring to earlier
where queen c1 is kind of a threat
i might play knight not sure between
knight d2 or
or castling
but i am i'm up a a rook and a knight
so life is good
i think i'll play knight d2 let's get
the knight involved
and then have the option between which
way to castle
oh thank you zeus gaming
oh gmd illusion has more obscure
openings
that i might be interested in
yeah i'm interested especially after
after seeing that first one
i'm actually curious because you you
initially
[Music]
asked about the lukini but were you
aware of this like very deep line
where black sacks everything or are we
just
aware of like the first few moves
yeah it's fun to explore sometimes
these uncharted waters
where of course like these openings are
are dubious at high levels
but it makes it a bit more rare
especially in practical play like even
like when uh when var var kobe and
raided
i asked to ask him if he was familiar
with it
and he admitted he'd never seen it
before he's like a top
top 150 in the world
i was talking about the lukini from
earlier i'll have to show that again
i made a study about it it's my most
recent study
hey it's corbla what's up corbla i
almost didn't see you there
shout out to corbla hope you're doing
well
can i play home by philip phillips
[Music]
i feel like that's copyrighted even
though it's a very strong
opening i'm gonna hold off
thumbnail idea could be gmd illusion
opening up a trench coat and showing
trappy openings
for sale in his jacket you would be
saying yeah
i'm interested interesting
yeah the the possibilities for thumbnail
ideas are endless
also have some fun with photoshop that
probably won't be the next video but
it'll be
it'll be released shortly within like a
week
what game did i find the most
instructive that i've played myself
um that's an interesting question i
haven't been asked
that specific one before
um there's a game actually
it was my first
so my freshman year of high school i
played robert hess
in this national high school
championships
and he beat me but it was a very
instructive game like there was a moment
in that game
i was much better but i just didn't
understand like a key concept
the concept of like prophylaxis but like
more positional prophylaxis
i think that that game and that moment
really helped broaden my understanding
of uh
more middle game strategy i'll have to
dig that up
there's some photo i can show a photo
probably
see if i can find a photo
so just to comment on this position
because this is something you'll see a
lot in pogchamps
where like one side has like a huge
material advantage and they're going
into an end game
and the general strategy is just to keep
everything defended to be patient
to simplify down eventually promote and
then not stalemate
so it sounds easy
uh which it should be but sometimes for
newer players it's uh
it's not super intuitive it takes some
long-term thinking
but now okay the strategy is just to
promote
opinion on 960 and 960 events
that's a lot of events that's more than
950 events
i assume you're asking about the the st
louis
which they're calling nine
what are they calling it
they're using roman numerals like 9 lx
9 that lacks yeah so 9 l is 50 10 is 10
or x is 10. um
so
yeah i think it's it's great for chess
like they're they're experimenting with
new formats i mean st in the chess club
has been very innovative
um with having
sometimes more obscure events and just
trying different
different types of formats so it should
be fun and they're getting like the best
players possible
like kasparov magnus hikaru
why don't you coach any of the
participants
um there's only like a limited number of
official coaches
i first i think the first edition of
pogchamps really the only official
coaches were
i think beautiful caro and danya
but that's not to say and especially
with this this addition
that it's a lot more
a lot more flexible and also kind of up
to the players
i had a streamed lesson
it was already about a month ago with
david pakman
who i actually i used to work with um
[Music]
maybe close to 18 months ago
um so i actually am like
uh i i have coach david so he's like the
main one i'm rooting for
but i'm also rooting for hafu because
she uh
i mean she sent so many raids and she's
been working probably the hardest
out of everyone
if you were a porn what porn would you
be oh a porn
etc i mean probably the e pawn right e
for eric
so i'll just have to live with the
d-pawn for now
change my name to derek
but yeah though i think the rules are
pretty lacks um
like hafu i think hafu has been working
with
a bunch of different gm's and hans
she was working with fidel the other day
i i did coach david pacman only chess
um but i think a lot of them are they're
playing games on chess.com and then
like we just usually chest to analyze
okay good game um
yeah especially for a newer player i
mean there were just a few
few mistakes resulting from
like being pressured early on in the
opening like d5 was the best move
um yeah here it just requires like a
slightly unnatural move as black you
have to really sense the danger
like really realize white's last move
realize the knights pinned and that
it's no longer actually defending the
pawn
um and that might drive you to playing a
move like this or this but then you have
to realize
either bishop move would then block the
queen from defending the
d-pawn
so really though the only two moves
that successfully defend the center are
this or this
f6 is actually the best move which is
not
not so natural usually not good uh
to weaken yourself but it's justified
here
bishop g7 is playable where you align
with the queen you lose a pond and then
you have this move
this is sort of like a gambit
um if we go further though
uh
yeah it was really so the bigger mistake
was yeah 5 is still playable
it was leaving the queen aligned with a
bishop
there's another like common common type
of tactic
i actually don't know if there's a great
way i guess
black should play queen d5 here
the queen's still perhaps a target
yeah this is already scary because i i
have bishop c4
um so maybe it was better not to play f5
but to play queen d5 here
and then just off the queen tree then if
i move my queen then you can win the
pawn
bye i know it's tough when like i i
really show no mercy
but overall like um i was definitely
definitely impressed for especially
playing against a player who's only been
playing for three months